طفل يطرق الابواب ليبيع البذور احيانا ثم
يبيع القرطاسيه هكذا كان في الماضي اما
اليوم فهو ملك يتربى على عرش تجاره السلع
الرياضيه عبر الانترنت ويملك ثروه تقدر
باكثر من 11 مليار دولار فمن هو مايكل
روبن مؤسس اهم متجر الكترونيه لبيع وتصنيع
السلع الرياضيه ولد مايكل روبن عام
1972 ونشا في ولايه بنسلفانيا وفي مكان
الاطفال يمضون اوقاتهم في اللعب كان مايكل
يبيع بذور الخضروات ولم يكن قد بلغ
الثامنه من عمره بعد ثم اضاف لعمله بيع
القرطاسيه وخدمه تجريف الثلج وقبل ان يبلغ
السادسه عشر من عمره كان لديه متجر الرسمي
للتزلج حمل اسمه مايك للتزلج والرياضه
واجهه مايكل ازمه الماليه مع تذبذب
المبيعات بعد موسم تزلج خال من الثلج
فالسداد من والده لسداد التزاماته شريطه
ان يعود الى الدراسه لكنهما لبث ان عقد
صفقه اخرى مع مدرسته الثانويه تسمح له
بمغادره المدرسه مبكرا لاداره مشروع متجر
التزلج الناشئ الخاص به الذي نما الى
امتلاكه وتشغيل خمسه متاجر للتزلج بعد
المدرسه التحق مايكل بجامعه فيلانوفا لكنه
تركها بعد ان حقق مكاسبك كبيره لصفقه
تجاريه عابره من بيع معدات فائضه عن
الحاجه وربح 75,000 دولار وحينها قام ببيع
متاجره واستخدام العائدات لتاسيس شركه بي
ار سبورتس التي سميت باسم الاحرف الاولى
من اسم والديه
زادت اعداداته كي بي ار من مليون دولار في
1993 الى 50 مليون دولار في
1995 وهو العام الذي بلغ فيه روبا 23 عاما
في عام
1998 انشا روبن جلوبال سبورت التي غيرت
اسمها لاحقا الى جي اس اي كومارس وهي شركه
لاداره عمليات التجاره الالكترونيه لكبار
تجار التجزئه مثلك
في عام 2001
مقابل مليارين و400 مليون دولار واشترى
منها كجزء من الصفقه ثلاثه شركات لم تكن
مهتمه بامتلاها هي رولا لا وشبرا نار
اضافه الى فناتيكس التي قد تكون الاهم في
عام 2018
استحوذ موقع المبيعات السريعه رولا لا على
شركه لجروب المنافسه فندمجت الشريتان في
لوغلد جروب اما فيما يتعلق بشركه شوبرا
نار فقد باعها مايكل في عام 2020 الى
فيديكس ليبقى محتفظا بحصص الله في سنه
تاكس وروج جاست جروب وبدلا من المنافسه مع
عملاقتين بيع التجزئه امازون وعلي بابا
جعل مايكل فاناكس متخصصه بحقوق بيع السلع
الرياضيه على مدى السنوات ال 10 التاليه
وقعت فنتكس عشرات من اتفاقيات الترخيص مع
فرق رياضيه محترفه وتجار تجزئه لبيع
مجموعه كبيره ومتنوعه من المعدات الرياضيه
وقد بلغت قيمتها السوقيه في ديسمبر 2022
واحدا وثلاثين مليار دولار يمتلك مايكل
البالغ من العمر 50 عاما نحو 33% من شركه
كما انه عضو مجلس اداره جروب هل وجهه
الاولى للتجاره الالكترونيه
تشمل رول على دوت كوم وجل دوت كوم وشوب
ريميم اوتليت دوت كوم ويملك ثروه تقدر
باحد 10 مليار و300 مليون دولار بعد ان
كان بائعا للبذور
[موسيقى]